love makes your soul crawl out of its
hiding place
true love stories never have endings
there is only one happiness in this life
to love and be loved
[Music]
love is something sent from heaven to
worry the hell out of you
the only thing we never get enough of or
give enough of is love
[Music]
true love comes quietly without banners
or flashing lights
if you hear bells get your ears checked
to love and be loved is to feel the sun
from both sides
life is the flower for which love is the
honey
being deeply loved by someone gives you
strength
while loving someone deeply gives you
courage
you always gain by giving love
[Music]
love recognizes no barriers
love is composed of a single soul
inhabiting two bodies
[Music]
we are most alive when we are in love
there is no charm equal to tenderness of
heart
the heart has its reasons of which
reason knows nothing
love is friendship that has caught fire
if you find someone you love in your
life hang on to that person
a simple i love you means more than
money
tis better to have loved and lost than
never to have loved at all
[Music]
to be brave is to love someone without
expecting anything in return
you know you're in love when you can't
fall asleep because reality is better
than your dreams
the best thing to hold on to in life is
each other
love is the flower you've got to let it
grow
[Music]
love is an endless act of forgiveness
at the touch of love everyone becomes a
poet
when we love we always strive to become
better than we are
when we strive to become better than we
are
everything around us becomes better
feel the love of people whom we love is
a fire that feeds our life
sometimes it's a form of love just to
talk to somebody that you have nothing
in common with
and still be fascinated by their
presence
[Music]
your task is not to seek love but merely
to seek and find all the barriers within
yourself that you have built against it
[Music]
when you love someone you love the
person as they are
not as you'd like them to be
[Music]
the greatest thing you'll ever learn is
to love and be loved in return
quiet love can drown out any fear
you don't love someone because they're
perfect
you love them in spite of the fact that
they're not
to love is to recognize yourself in
another
when you realize you want to spend the
rest of your life with somebody you want
the rest of your life to start as soon
as possible
when there is great love there are
miracles
[Music]
passion makes the world go round
love just makes it a safer place
women are meant to be loved
not to be understood
you know it's love when all you want is
for that person to be happy
even if you're not part of their
happiness
love is the magician that pulls man out
of his own hat
[Music]
lots of people want to ride with you in
a limo
but what you want is someone who will
take the bus with you when the limo
breaks down
continue to share your heart with people
even if it is broken
[Music]
there is always some madness in love
but there is also some reason to the
madness
love is like the wind you can't see it
but you can feel it
[Music]
love has nothing to do with what you
expect to get
only with what you are expecting to give
which is everything
[Music]
when you are missing someone time seems
to move slower
and when you are falling in love with
someone time seems to be moving faster
it is a curious thought but it is only
when you see people looking ridiculous
that you realize just how much you love
them
[Music]
in the end we discover that to love and
let go can be the same thing
the pleasure of love lasts but a moment
the pain of love lasts a lifetime
love is a thing that is full of cares
and fears
a purpose of human life no matter who is
controlling it is to love whoever is
around to be loved
romance is the glamour that turns the
dust of everyday life into a golden haze
[Music]
love is the strange bewilderment which
overtakes one person on account of
another person
one word frees us of all the weight and
pain of life
that word is love
[Music]
it is better to be hated for what you
are than to be loved for what you are
not
let the beauty of what you love be what
you do
[Music]
love is the ultimate expression of the
will to live
only true love can fuel the hard work
that awaits you
[Music]
love all trust few
do wrong to none
[Music]
a life lived in love will never be dull
love is shown more in deeds than in
words
the love we give away is the only love
we keep
trust your intuition and be guided by
love
[Music]
he is not a lover who does not love
forever
never love anyone who treats you like
your ordinary
[Music]
a man is already halfway in love with
any woman who listens to him
you don't marry someone you could live
with
you marry someone you cannot live
without
[Music]
[Music]
you